allez un petit tour de magie alors avant
de le faire je rappelle que le magic
delirium après avoir triomphé à
l'olympia ou chose rarissime il a fallu
rajouter des dates et rajouter des dates
c'est quand même juste une petite salle
où net de combien 3000 places à l'huile
de noix la 2000 places dans qu'il est
partout en france vous allez sur le net
idem pour mon florent peyre qui va dans
jeunes ont un petit peu moins faire un
carton à vos folies bergères mail en ce
moment pareil internet il est entoure la
valse ce soir est maintenant attention
ok on va le faire avec jean-michel avec
un cher jean michel
toutes les cartes sont différentes les
unes des autres sinon c'est un triste
tour
vous prenez une carte was a aucune
espèce d'importance vous la regardez
vous la signer sur la phase la phase la
carte pataras nom se retrouve la face si
tu l'as sin sur le dos ça sera vachement
plus faciles à retrouver bien et jean
michel vous me dites stop quand vous les
schirrheinois tant pis si parfait alors
voilà ce que je vais faire
cette carte est maintenant unique au
monde je mets le paquet dont l'étui
comme ceux ci et regardez bien mes mains
sont vides
et pourtant ici il ya trois enveloppes
choisi une enveloppe ma poule
celle du milieu celle là est dans cette
enveloppe il ya une carte et une seule
mais invisible attention attention aux
nazis fleuron oui vise jean michel vas-y
vas-y vas-y dit ok c'est pas grave on va
aller encore plus loin tu es fils
florent n'ya rien enveloppe tu peux
vérifier
je prends maintenant la baguette magique
du 9 3
désolé ce que j'ai fait une grosse
erreur
florent tu vas me tenir ce couteau s'il
te plaît avec toute la force et la can
dont tu es capable
ok très bien il n'y a rien là on le fait
vérifier tous les spectateurs
l'étui est fermé j'insère l'étui ici
dans l' enveloppe à trois noms